[Music]
guys today we are going to be learning
how to make
puff pastry now at the beginning of the
quarantine i started baking
and using store bought puff pastry like
beverage farms and stuff like that by
the middle of quarantine i realized
in order to step up my baking game i
needed to make
my own puff pastry i need to understand
the science behind puff pastry so i
enlisted the help of my friend julia she
came over one day and we
sat down and she taught me how to make
puff pastry from scratch now legend has
it that puff pastry is very hard to make
there's the folding of the butter into
the dough and then there's the
temperature part of it where you have to
keep the dough
and the butter at a certain temperature
so it doesn't melt but at the end of it
all i realize it's not that scary and
it's not that daunting to make
it's actually very very easy although
tedious it is super super manageable and
i'm going to teach you how to make puffs
pastry from scratch
today
[Music]
all right first let's go through the
ingredients we'll need two cups
minus two tablespoons of all-purpose
flour and yes that's a very specific
amount of flour we'll also need a
quarter teaspoon of salt
we'll need three quarter cups plus two
tablespoons
of cold water and finally we'll need one
and a half sticks of unsalted butter
room temperature let's move on into
making our dough
so first i like to sift the flour into a
large mixing bowl get out any large
clumps of flour
next add your salt and then add your
cold water now combine all the
ingredients together and work it into a
dough
now once you have your dough it should
be a sticky dough forming into a bowl
and because it's a sticky dough you want
to use a lot of flour to dust your work
surface and cover it with the mixing
bowl
and now we're going to let it rest for
15 minutes just so that it can get to
room temperature and during that time
we're going to head over to our butter
hopefully you've taken out the butter
like an hour beforehand so it can get
down to room temperature if not
throw it in the microwave and microwave
it for roughly i don't know like 20
seconds
15 seconds don't melt the butter you
just want it to be at room temperature
so whenever you do have room temperature
butter
go ahead and stir it and get it to be a
smooth
buttery paste
all right now we have our dough ball
ready to go at room temp we have the
butter
at room temp and it's all whipped up now
we are finally ready
for the folding process and here is fold
number one to begin we'll need a rolling
pin
a rubber scraper and a pastry knife like
always when baking flour your work area
generously and
gently press down on your dough and form
it into a mini
rectangle with your hands once it's
pushed down i find it easier to roll out
so next use your rolling pin
and roll out that dough into a 16 by 12
rectangle
now once you have it rolled out imagine
your dough
in sections of thirds seeing your dough
in thirds is going to be super key
so we're gonna take our butter we're
gonna apply it to two thirds of our
dough
surface so what i like to do is draw
imaginary line where we section off one
third of the dough and that one third
we're not gonna touch it with any butter
the remaining two thirds of it we're
gonna lather on the butter now be sure
to only use a quarter of your butter at
this point because we're going to be
repeating this process
four four times now once you have the
butter applied
go ahead and fold the unbuttered third
of the dough
over at the cut off line over into the
buttered section and now you're gonna
have
the remaining one-third of the buttered
section
exposed and we're gonna fold that over
to the part we just fold it in
so it's kind of like you're making one
of those uh travel brochure pamphlets
with
dough and i talk about all this folding
stuff for a reason because this folding
stuff is the very reason why there are
layers
in puff pastry and also the very reason
why we're going to put this whole thing
into the fridge so that the butter
doesn't actually melt into the flour
we want to distinguish that butter and
the flour
as separate entities so that they can
retain that layering effect
so from here i like to fold in the edges
and i'm going to take some plastic wrap
and wrap it in plastic wrap and we're
going to place it into the fridge for
15 minutes just enough for the butter to
harden up all right after 15 minutes
it is time for fold number two out comes
the dough
we're gonna put it back on a floured
surface and again
roll it out into a 16 by 12 rectangle
all right so again
repeating the last step in fact the next
two steps are also repeating
this step in the last step it's all the
same it's all ditto
so imagine in thirds again apply butter
on two thirds of your dough
fold the unbuttered third into the
middle of your dough
and fold the remaining butter dough on
top of the rest of it making that
pamphlet again
i guess there is one thing i do
differently at this step since there
already is
butter layered in i like to also fold
the pamphlet shape that it's in
into itself one more time just to create
some more layers since the butter is
already there
so i'm just constantly folding and
folding and folding and folding now
there is actually a formula out there
where you based on the number of times
you fold and the number of times you
repeat the process
you can actually calculate the number of
final layers you'll have
at the moment i don't want to do any
math so i'm not going to tell you what
that equation is
i'm sure you can wikipedia and find out
for yourself anyways back to our dough
once it's folded in like this
go ahead and place it back to the fridge
for another 15 minutes
all right round number three ditto
imagine in thirds we're going to lather
it up on two things fold it up to the
one third side and then
halfway and you fold it to the center
one more time yada yada and by this time
you'll actually start feeling the dough
feel actually buttery while you're
working on it your hands are warm and
you know
some of that butter will escape here and
there you'll actually feel that
butteriness
in your dough so as you feel that
butteriness in your hands it's a
constant reminder to work fast and get
that thing back into the fridge as soon
as you can so once you're done with fold
number three let's go ahead and place it
back into the fridge for another
15 minutes all right and round number
four we are now going to do it
one last time same exact thing are you
tired yet but you know what all this
hard work and all this highly
sophisticated engineering of butter
folded into dough
it's gonna pay off in the long run
you're gonna thank yourself once you
bite into that puff pastry
after we bake it so after foley is one
final time you are now officially
done give yourself a pound on the back
and this
is equal to 12 servings of egg tarts 12
servings of pastries
however you want it but that also
depends on how much pastry you use how i
use up this pastry it's about 12
servings for me and if you don't know
what to use your puff pastry for
if you're into something savory at the
moment i have a delicious curry puff
video
or you can check out my portuguese egg
tart video which is my fave
if you're into something sweet at the
moment anyways like always make sure to
like and subscribe feel free to leave a
comment down below if you have any ideas
for me to make next and i will see you
next time
[Music]
you